hospitals in at least 25 states face a
critical shortage of nurses doctors and
other staff amid
the surging pandemic according to a
recent research from stat news
not all hospitals are affected equally
however as we learn by looking at two
very different facilities one in
nebraska and one in new york
senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula shows us
how supply issues and the hard earned
lessons of past covet spikes
are making a difference now on the
plains of nebraska
lexington regional health center has
just 25
hospital beds and four doctors to battle
the county's coveted positivity rate
of 28 percent 1500 miles away in new
york
northwell health runs 23 hospitals with
nearly 6
000 beds and 4 500 doctors
when kovit first attacked the country
new york was the epicenter
and northwell hospitals were on the
front lines we saw
over 85 000 covid patients since the
crisis began
ceo michael dowling says northwest size
and experience
during disasters like september 11th
offered some advantages
we did what was known as load balancing
we were able to use our transport
network
and move patients from queens to
westchester
to eastern long island if we had not
been able to do that
those hospitals in queens would have
been overwhelmed
small hospitals like lexington regional
have fewer resources
with the explosion of cases across the
midwest larger hospitals that usually
take their transfer patients
are now turning them away kovit has
really left us and in a bit of a
situation
hospital ceo leslie marsh is struggling
with a staffing gap
46 employees have tested positive for
the virus
four nurses have resigned and there's a
shortage of traveling nurses
who usually fill in while we have five
ventilators right now
we don't have the staff to care for five
ventilated patients
what are the healthcare professionals at
your hospital telling you about their
concerns
about the coming months nurses are
getting burned out and leaving they want
a job that's not
so stressful when it comes to ppe like
gloves
lexington regional only has about a two
week supply
during the spring surge marsh used a
lifeline
getting shipments from the non-profit
angel flight central
which serves rural hospitals in 10
states and it was a lifesaver
literally a lifesaver and i think that
we'll probably have to reach out to them
again here soon
these are masks these are n95s these are
n95s
in new york supplies come in here about
30 deliveries a day actually come in
here from all over the globe
north wells 85 thousand square foot
warehouse
is overflowing with ppe
northwell didn't need to rely on the
federal government's dwindling stockpile
it uses an automated system to respond
to each hospital's needs
this must have been massively reassuring
to your staff
we were able to tell them we have enough
supplies we can assure you that
that was enormous when you talk to some
of the staff
are any of them telling you i can't do
this again
i have not held much of that at all i
haven't had anybody come to me or talk
to me
and say i wouldn't do this again they
recognized
that they saved so many lives
we all go into healthcare primarily
because we want to make a difference and
so
it is an honor and an obligation and
you know a duty and a privilege to be
able to be in this building
northwell health where i am on staff
estimates it has the resources to ride
out a year of projected lost revenue
the reality is states and hospitals are
engaging in bidding wars against each
other for ppe
and for medical workers smaller
hospitals like lexington regional cannot
compete and often lose out
the hospital tells us it only has 12
days of
cash left on hand wow so tara with all
these cutbacks and with the staff
shortages and losses what are doctors
and nurses
doing to keep themselves in this
all-important fight
well tony both ceos really stress that
staff is their most valuable resource
and asset and there are things that
leadership can do in terms of being
there on the front lines walking the
halls
talking to the staff having open lines
of communication and then little things
like lexington regional ceo told us
they brought in tacos one saturday night
to help feed the staff
north wall which obviously has bigger
more resources was able to provide
things like daycare
hotel rooms for staff workers so they
didn't have to go home and expose their
family
counseling services but both of the ceos
said that really what helps motivate the
staff are the victories are the
survivors uh you know at my hospital
lennox hill which is affiliated with
part of northwell
they would play the song here comes the
sun every time a patient
was taken off a ventilator throughout
the loudspeakers in the hospital every
time a patient was discharged
and hearing that song really helps
motivate the staff
and the patients that is a beautiful
anecdote there i love that thank you
very much doctor tara noula we
appreciate it